I know who you are so at the end of
episode 20 we finally reveal his avatar
it's avatar is Barry Allen I am the
future flash at the beginning of episode
21 Barry gets the faith's avatar and ask
him all these questions how did it
happen how did you become so evil how
did you because why are you targeting me
and all of those answers are we reveal
within the first five minutes of the
episode I just avatars a version of
Barry from the future and he remembers
everything that Barry does how are we
ever going to come up with a plan to
stop him so after Barry reveals to the
team of saboteurs the team tries to
figure out a way to be ahead of so
avatar for once I want to stop you from
making new memories what are you talking
about sabotage knows everything we're
going to do because he remembers doing
and he's a future Barry so what if Barry
can't remember what we're doing now they
decide let's short let's zap Barry
short-term memory so that sabotage has
no memory of what the team did to stop
them okay that's a do it how do you feel
I feel fine you see he feels fine Barry
sorry who's Barry I'm not fine
[Music]
everybody brand-new flash coming tonight
going to reveal all the answers as they
say in the first five minutes of the
episode there's going to be a new brand
of the plastering giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so the really
cool thing about this is that they're
not going to stretch this out to the end
of the season I'm so happy about that
anytime they do big reveals a lot of
times you don't get the complete picture
- like the very last episode even with
the reverse flash at the end of season
one there was still a lot of questions
in that final episode especially with
that Jay Garrick tease that was it
that's my cue to leave so they will do
something similar this year even though
you know Barry will obviously fix the
problem of sabotage but in doing so will
create a bigger problem that will push
them into season foreign service like
the first big arc like oh my god what's
happened how are we going to do this so
I love the fact that Cisco has a big
chart here in the background normally
it'd be Harrison wells to do this he's
the one that explains zoom the
reverse-flash coming back like they had
a big chart board this is the version
from this point in the timeline it'll be
fun to try and pick through that and
they have like a möbius script drawn
here so it's almost like everything that
they do still leads to Salvatore because
he's a legit version of Barry's it just
remembers everything in finds ways to
counteract the changes the team flash
makes so that Barry still becomes him in
the future the reason I think that the
black flash and the Speed Force haven't
directly acted against avatar is because
Barry always turns into Savitt are no
matter what happens so if they stops
avatar it doesn't stop Barry in the past
from becoming saboteur so that doesn't
get into any of the killer frost stuff
that happens during the episode she's a
big part of this last arc of the season
all about her becoming the version that
we're going to see going forward on this
show in not coming back to being the
normal version of Caitlin that's what
they've done in the past like you see
killer froth but then they always sort
of reset to base Caitlin I think the
thing that most people want to see on
the show is progression and growth so
they don't make the same mistakes season
over season you don't just roll big
changes back after characters go through
this big development and even though
they'll explain it in the first five
minutes of the episode the big twist of
sabotage the reason why he wanted to
become the guy
of speed God speed style and everybody's
wondering if he's ever going to show up
on the TV show but it's because he wants
to get rid of all the pain and suffering
that he feels that's the thing with
killer frost she wants to get rid of the
katelin part of herself that still feels
all the trauma of the stuff that's
happened the last couple of seasons
losing Ronnie in season one getting
captured and terrorized by zoom
being crippled by the fear of hurting
the people that she loves so it'll be
interesting to see how grant gustin's
performance conveys a lot of this future
Barry I think it's a little bit soon I
think if they were going to do this
avatar work I would have rather seen it
in a later season but part of the core
operating mission of the show is that
you don't hold back like if you're going
to do a big story do it now and find
something even bigger later on so if you
feel like the whole arc of this season
was completely rushed it's only because
they're making way for something even
bigger and I don't think that they're
going to bun up against the flash movie
it's not like they're trying to get
through story before the flash movie and
the DC EU takes characters that they
won't be able to use they're already
bringing back some really big DC TV
characters that are also in the movies
I think the flash TV show is you're
trying to go as big as possible as fast
as possible in case they don't get the
opportunity later on so I will be doing
a bunch of flash bonus videos every week
during the break it's only going to be a
little while before we get news about
season four after this season end so
start thinking about the videos that you
guys want me to do after the finale airs
and I will be doing some comic book
stuff too but I think most people don't
read comics so it to be a little more
careful about the way I do comic book
videos but there's some other really big
stuff on the other DC TV shows that is
coming up so the producers have settled
this very publicly so I don't consider
it spoilers so I'll say you know
Supergirl Superman is coming back for
the finale make sure you watch it I'll
totally do a video for it it'll air the
same week as the flash finale in the
arrow finale everything is going to get
their finale during the same week so no
worries but the arrow stuff is even
bigger you all know that Deathstroke is
coming back
there's the Titan show that's coming up
they're going to kill a couple big
characters in that finale I have some
predictions about that and they've
already announced that one of the big
villain characters from this season on
all the DC TV shows will
not be coming back next season and he
could be one of the people that they
kill up but I'll talk about that during
my arrow video this week just make sure
you watch all the DC TV shows for the
next couple of weeks through the finale
because that's when all the really big
stuff is happening so just a reminder
there's a new flash ring giveaway
happening when I post my episode video
later tonight my Guardians Easter eggs
will post in a couple hours then I'll
post that flash episode video so whole
bunch of comic book stuff happening this
week be sure and check the video tab on
my channel if you feel like you missed a
couple things but while you wait for
that to pose click here for brand new
flash and click here for brand new
spider-man homecoming thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight